nice to load trucks in Secaucus I would
take the bus down to Kelly Boulevard and
walk all the way the [ __ ] Seahawks
and load trucks is when I was you know
just 17 I loaded trucks to roadway
roadway on the docks me at 9:00 in the
morning oh my god picking the road up in
Volkswagen Oh things and but it was like
16 and now yeah I know I think there's
like 14 bucks and is hanging in there
gold so we you know do two or three
night and then we get off work and just
go right to the bar and drink so we put
us ourselves to sleep so 9:30 in the
morning we're at the bar drinking bud
but can what parts are open at 9:30 in
the morning all of them yeah all of them
laughs so when I quit high school liquid
high school my mom had a bomb before I
can 29th and Bergen line but a drinking
spot was the last bar in New Jersey and
he took the bus to the city you have to
go through a living City and then a
picture up by the post office and it
takes you right down into Lincoln tell
me you pass at gas station yep and
you're right there the basketball all of
our degree Holcomb Boulevard ease
protect I needed a job and I were I
needed a job off the books I was
collecting unemployment from a [ __ ]
yeah this is it on the eighth is what
you did in those days you could pick up
a job off the books at pages six seven
hundred and collect four or five hundred
from unemployment and live like a
[ __ ] doctor
so most people had the Year scam I love
how Jim didn't even blink like I would
laugh and Jim's like yeah what happened
thereafter oh I know ten guys I did yeah
this is - this is I know people that
purposely got laid off like they had to
deal with the buzzing just let me know
pay me three bills a week unemployment
I'll make it happen I got a better job
it's off the books
everything works off the books everybody
collects on the check it was [ __ ]
brilliant so I went in there when their
guy's name was Teddy Martynyuk he had
played for the Chicago Bulls [ __ ]
big-time drunk if you look him up he
recently died and I looked among those
in the column and apologize because I
destroyed his world for like six months
but the first thing he said to me
because I could hi but there's one
problem
I got one shift that is 7:00 to 3:00
he goes but let me explain something you
can't be late
and I'm like [ __ ] drinks at seven like
in my mind who the [ __ ] drinks itself
and so I would have Monday nights from 5
to 2 or 5 to 3 and then Wednesdays I'd
have to go to Union City and open the
bar at 7:00 stay there till 3:00 first
day I was [ __ ] late what do I give a
[ __ ]
then he had you open the bar at 7-7 the
morning when I got to him there was 30
[ __ ] people that ready to kill me
okay I never saw that before Jeff I
never saw that how late were you like 20
minutes 30 minutes I was maybe 15
minutes away I had to set the alarms up
while I went inside when I came out they
were all at the ball look if I'm right
then we're gonna kill them and they all
would do two shots of whiskey with
scotch or something strong would it be
back or water back one though ice these
were real people this was not crying
happy Valentine oh no no no none another
these are people that while they go to
get to drink they don't want you looking
at them because the hand would shake as
they were going to get to drink and then
they'd pull down and you should give him
another shot and they put that down and
they take a beer and [ __ ] drink that
and get on the bus to New York that's
the way their life is and I'm gonna just
to keep them sane that's just to get the
party started to get them on that bus
two shots at 7:00 the [ __ ] morning I
never saw that before in my life at 17 I
was like wow I get it now but yeah and
they were all great tippers so you made
50 bucks by 7:30 couple scrag was walked
to the same thing whiskey on let me get
to boom-boom or beer out it was
something that I had never seen before
my mom drank she had friends to join but
I didn't know who the [ __ ] went into a
bar at 7:00 a.m. just to get today start
and just that just that you're 17 years
old you're serving people in a bar this
is just crazy
listen and then you would add up the
tabs for the night and what you had to
do is put them in a regular envelope and
put them in the top shelf from the
refrigerator okay
so I went and bought the same envelopes
and I would go in there at 4 o'clock in
the morning I would go into the city and
snort coke of my friend and go like a
rock concert or something and the way
back I'm going to take your time because
they're gonna stop at the bombing and
quick withdrawal my ATM machine I called
it
that was my first pay TN machine I would
go over there in the middle all night I
rip open the envelope take 200 out put
the rest in and put the date on it and
he was blaming on the girl before me
only the girl that before me I grew up
with it so one day like a boyfriend came
to me cuz you gotta stop robbing that
blade dead blade with all my [ __ ]
girl